was kann der körper eigentlich überleben
wurde in unsere grenzen und wann wird es
lebensgefährlich die zehn dinge die wir
unbedingt vermeiden sollten wenn wir
nicht frühzeitig sterben wollen das ist
aber schon verblüffend was der körper so
alles ausfällt so kann er zum beispiel
eine menge blut verlieren wie viel jetzt
in klick zum kleinsten fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir hatten ja sehr letztlich schon beim
thema weltraum es gibt ein paar
bedingungen die absolut fertig sind im
weltraum ist es zum beispiel die
temperatur und das vakuum
ein mensch kann dort nur ein paar
sekunden über leben aber auch hier auf
der erde gibt es solche bedingungen und
wir sollten sie meiden und uns darauf
gut vorbereiten zwar gibt es hier kein
vakuum aber ab einer bestimmten höhe
wird die luft verdammten und der druck
niedrig auf der 10 also die höhe
ja ich habe es selbst schon in der
atacama wüste in chile erlebt ab 2.500
metern wird es unangenehm
das fängt schon mit dem sauerstoffmangel
an das herz hängt wie wild an zu
schlagen damit die muskeln genügend
sauerstoff bekommen
hinzu kommen kopfschmerzen schwindel und
übelkeit der verminderte
sauerstoffgehalt im blut macht die
gefäßwände durchlässiger blutplasma
tritt vermehrt ins gewebe über ab 4500
metern wird die wahrnehmungsfähigkeit
getrübt und nach kann je nachdem der tod
eintreten
ursachen sind dann
flüssigkeitsansammlung im körper zum
beispiel im gehirn oder in der lunge
aber auch die niedrigen temperaturen
setzten im körper zu und verbunden mit
dem gedrückten bewusstsein können
fehlentscheidungen dann zum tod führen
damit wären wir auch schon bei der
niedrigen temperatur auf der neuen ist
zu kaltes wasser in wasser haben wir
nämlich kaum eine chance etwas gegen den
wärmeverlust zu tun es fehlt jegliche
isolierungen vier grad kaltem wasser
können wir höchstens 30 minuten
überleben wenn dieser zeit beginnen aber
schon sehr schnelle tödliche prozesses
werden stresshormone ausgeschüttet um
die wärmeproduktion anzuregen wir fangen
an zu zittern
aber beides hat keinen effekt im wasser
da wir die erzeugte wärme sofort ans
wasser abgeben das zittern beschleunigt
das sogar noch ist die körpertemperatur
vom standardwert 37 grad auch um die 30
grad celsius gefallen hören wir auf zu
zittern
ab jetzt wird es angenehm deswegen wir
uns auch kaum noch während wir haben
keine energie mehr kälte und schmerz
werden nicht mehr empfunden alles läuft
jetzt verlangsamt bei etwa 49 5
gratulieren wir das bewusstsein das herz
schlägt dessen noch zwei bis drei mal in
der minute wir atmen kaum noch und ist
die temperatur unter 20 grad celsius
gefallen dann sterben
da kommen wir direkt mal zur
körpertemperatur auf der acht die
absolute obergrenze ist 42 3 grad wie
wird eigentlich nie erreicht vorher
greift der organismus zahlreiche
maßnahmen um das zu fehlern
oberhalb dieser temperatur gibt es
nämlich rührei in unserem körper
die proteine also die eiweiße in unserem
körper werden steif und damit kommt der
gesamte organismus zum erliegen
deshalb ist der aufenthalt in heißen
räumen auch nur kurz möglich auf der 7
also wie sauna in einer feuchten brauner
können es erwachsene bei 110 grad ist zu
ungefähr vier minuten aushalten in einem
brennenden haus geht es längert wenn man
nicht direkt mit den flammen in kontakt
kommt bis zu zehn minuten gehen hier
weil die luftfeuchtigkeit deutlich
geringer ist aber achtung kinder fallen
schon in einem heißen auto nach wenigen
minuten in ohnmacht und können sterben
der grund bezogen auf ihr körpervolumen
haben sie ein viel größere oberfläche
durch die schnelle aufgeheizt werden und
schneller flüssigkeit verliert ja und
auf der sechs haben wir zum dritten mal
hitze auch die sonneneinstrahlung plus
warmes wetter kann uns umbringen hier
sind die temperaturen deutlich geringer
als zum beispiel in der sauna aber
trotzdem lebensgefährlich die schweiz
produktion funktioniert dann nicht mehr
hier steigt die körpertemperatur auf
über 40 grad an und der kreislauf wird
überlastet es kommen zum
kreislaufzusammenbruch die organe werden
nicht mehr ausreichend mit sauerstoff
versorgt in der folge kann es zu
zahlreichen komplikationen bis hin zum
tod kommen auf die fünf wassertiefe der
menschen am tiefsten getaucht ist hat es
auf 214 meter wassertiefe gebrachte
unserer mass sterblich ist aber tödlich
von ab 25 bis 35 meter wassertiefe ist
unsere lunge maximal zusammengepresst
fangen die lungengefäße an zu platzen
wir ertrinken an gewebsflüssigkeit von
innen auch wenn wir kein oder nur wenig
wasser geschluckt haben die vier auch
ein problem als taucher sauerstoff wir
können so lange überleben die sich
sauerstoff im blut befindet zehn minuten
sind das maximal aber lange vorher schon
wird unser gehirn stark geschädigt nach
20 sekunden ohne sauerstoff werden wir
ohnmächtig nach zwei bis drei minuten
fangen an den zellen geschädigt zu
werden nach fünf minuten haben wir einen
massiven hirnschaden
dann nach zehn minuten sind wir klinisch
tot auf der 3 ohne wasser ohne wasser zu
trinken da können wir etwas länger
überleben rund eine woche ist kommt
extrem darauf an wie viel wasser wir
verlieren in der wüste ist dass deutlich
mehr womit wir erst drei bis vier tagen
werden im idealfall können soll bis zu
zwölf tage seien trinken wir zu wenig
wasser steigt die gips konzentration in
unserem körper immer weiter an und die
körpereigenen gifte schädigen die organe
reparabel multi organ versagen
herzinfarkt oder schlaganfall sind dann
die meisten todesursachen auf der zwei
essen ein bis zwei monaten können wir
ohne essen überleben kommt wenig darauf
an wie big wir sind der körper lebt
nämlich ohne nahrung von der eigenen
substanz als erstes werden die noch
vorhandenen kohlenhydrate abgebaut dann
das fettgewebe dann die muskeln und am
ende haut nieren lunge und knochen
nach etwa 30 prozent verlust des
körpergewichts sterben wir das kommt
natürlich auch auf das übergewicht und
auf der eins wie viel blut können wir
ein verlieren wir kennen es vom
blutspenden man kann schon offene ganze
ordentliche menge gut verzichten ohne
dass es irgendwelche bedeutsamen folgen
hätte 30% blutverlust kann der mensch
kompensieren auf 40 prozent wird es aber
echt schwierig ab jetzt werden geräte
nicht mehr richtig mit blut versorgt und
auch das herz hat probleme wenn die
herzkammer nicht mehr richtig mit blut
versorgt werden kann das schwere
herzrhythmusstörungen zur folge haben
die organe werden nicht mehr ausreichend
mit blut versorgt wir sterben an
kreislaufversagen so jetzt wisst ihr was
unbedingt zu vermeiden ist mehr
überleben fix gibt es hier wenn ihr mir
hier ein abo aufs auge drückt verpasst
ihr nichts dafür mehr aber auch
unbedingt einen auf die glocke geben ja
und hier geht es weiter mit den besten
krieg zum videos und mir bleibt nur noch
zu sagen bis dann bleibt gesund